si l'on pose une question délicate à sa
mère elle ne va pas répondre où elle va
dévier sur un autre sujet aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui je peux ce que je peux
faire c'est assumé mes responsabilités
avec ma famille il y a toujours ce qui
vous influence dans le mauvais sens et
c'est peut-être même le problème
principal ne pas pouvoir parler
ouvertement avec la famille je pense que
les jeunes en martinique devrait plus
aussi s'investit aussi dans la vie
catholique
il n'y a dans cette cathédrale ni
barbadienne literie dadian dit
dominicaine ou francophone la zone
arc-en-ciel de honneur et de plénitude
diront certains
[Applaudissements]